- Hey everybody, I'm Alex Hatcher.
I'm with Slalom, and I'm a part
of our AWS Cloud capability.
And today, let's see, it looks
like we're a slide ahead.
Today we're gonna be
talking about our approach
to accelerating legacy modernization.
So throughout the talk,
what we're gonna cover,
our Zero Legacy campaign.
For our clients, we're
seeing that modernization
is a strategic importance, and
it's important to us as well.
So we'll cover that.
We will also discuss our,
like, what we're seeing
in the landscape and
with our clients today.
We'll see some of the challenges
that our clients are facing
and some of the opportunities
that come out of that.
You know, we're also really
excited about a customer
like our most recent public
customer story with La-Z-Boy,
where we were able to
move them to Zero Legacy
by retiring their Z Series mainframe.
So, looking forward to
telling you more about that.
Zero Legacy.
So first off, what is legacy exactly?
To us, we see legacy, like
a legacy system is anything
that you have to change,
that you have to look at,
or that is a barrier to modernization.
So like, or innovating in
the way that you want to.
So like, I think we've probably
all been in that situation,
or a lot of us have,
where we're like, hey,
like, the product team wants to innovate.
We wanna see something new.
We want to, we see an
opportunity for our business,
but then when it comes to
a technical discussion,
we start to see, oh,
but we've gotta touch
this, you know, system X.
And if we do that, everybody
kind of starts to pull back
and we kind of see that idea
or that creativity die on the vine
right there in that moment.
To us, like that's really
what our Zero Legacy campaign
is about, is solving that problem.
We wanna move you into a
position where you're able
to think creatively, be imaginative,
and not have the drag of legacy
on your, like in your space.
So.
So, let's see.
So a key qualifier that we see
for a lot of legacy systems,
typically they're monolithic,
typically they're stateful.
Typically what we see
in modern architectures
is that they are microservice,
so non-monolithic,
and that they're stateless.
So there's a need for us
to kind of make like a paradigm shift
between the two overall.
And mainframe specifically is, you know,
like z/OS AS/400 workloads
are very stateful,
very monolithic and centralized.
So, you know, that's kind of
like a key candidate for us.
Like, it is in a part of
our strategic initiative
in terms of what we wanna modernize.
You know, what we're
hearing from our clients
in this space is that the.
What we're hearing from
our clients in this space
is that like their costs are rising
and that it's difficult to hire.
I'll give you an example
of one of our clients
in the gov space is, so
the original developers
of their mainframe hire,
they trained their children
to actually be able to maintain the system
after they're retired.
So it's a very real scenario
for them where, you know,
Dad is like on the beach
getting a phone call from his
daughter who's saying,
hey, I'm in the COBOL code.
I see you in the comments.
What were you thinking here?
You know, like when we modified this
or when we created that.
So that, like, to me, that says,
our clients are being
extremely creative about
how they are trying to
solve that skills problem
of these legacy technologies.
So we see that the problem
is there, but so why now?
You know, and we see the
pressure from, you know,
like the cost and the timing overall.
But what's like, you know,
what's kind of moving us forward?
And AI is a big component of that,
probably no surprises for anybody.
What we're seeing in the AI
space, like these mainframes,
you know, or AS/400 legacy
systems kind of have their,
the being able to access
the code, the data.
Monitoring real-time information is more
of a black box than anything
that we're gonna deal with,
like in a cloud environment where we're
like heavily monitored
in a microservice level.
So Generative AI has been
extremely good at allowing us
to reverse engineer those systems
and in a way that we never have before.
So what we used to do in
those systems is we would have
numerous solution architects
that would descend on a large
code base, describe that,
then synthesize higher
understandings of that code base,
build diagrams, and then, you
know, get feedback on that
to validate what they're finding.
And that's extremely labor
intensive, it's extremely costly,
but what we're, you know,
and what GenAI has opened up
for us is what we can do
now is we could provision
a Kendra index.
We could provision a
Bedrock knowledge base,
and we can essentially zip up
our code, load it into that,
into an S3 bucket, index it with Kendra.
And then access our
knowledge base through an MCP
and like Q Developer or Q CLI,
and we're able pretty
much with within an hour
to start asking questions about
our code to understand it.
That can support a process where
we can start documenting it
and open that up with
a very little overhead.
So I think just that in itself,
the ability to like use Generative AI
to assist in the re-engineering process
is really driving us forward.
So we're using Generative AI
in our modernization in
a few different ways.
We've already touched on the
reverse engineering process
and how we're able to really open up
like these legacy
systems and describe them
and understand them in a way
that we really never have been before.
We're also, we're still
seeing productivity gains
from using Generative AI just to augment
like our traditional SDLC process.
So now imagine I'm using
my preferred coding agent,
which is definitely gonna be Q or Q CLI.
And now what I'm able to
do, not only am I able
to just use the default model,
which we've all seen is like
a great productivity increase.
But now we're again able
to bring that context of
that legacy code into that
process where we can still use
that, you know, to augment
our traditional SDLC
with tremendous productivity
gains, like usually about 30%
and sometimes more depending
on the problem space.
So now let's look at our
forward engineering process.
So if we're able to, like
we see that we're able
to describe these systems,
we're able to extract
that knowledge from them.
We're also now, like we've seen really,
really great advancements with spec-driven
development toolkits like Kiro, Kiro CLI.
That announcement that just came out
where there's opportunity now for us
to lean into the future,
which could be spec-driven
development supported by,
like by what we're able to extract
in our reverse engineering process.
So like, just to try to paint
a bit of a picture of that,
not only are we able like
through like to use Generative AI
to kind of get those like a
high level domain explanation
of what the system does,
but we're also able to
decompose those domains
and we're also able to look at and define
and see the execution paths
of the functions that we need to do,
or the subroutines that
need to be executed
to achieve a task from end-to-end.
And, you know, if, you know,
if we're thinking about it,
it's kind of like that's very
similar to what we think of
as a microservice, a single execution path
of a single function.
And so with context
and with that fully documented
as a part of our process,
like we start to move into
territory where it makes sense
and it's completely possible
to do a more of a spec-driven
development process that's bringing all of
that information into context
with, again, full traceability
of that specification
back to the original code.
So we can validate as we go.
So, so far we've talked
a lot about technology,
and technology is extremely important,
but I think the one thing
that we really do at Slalom
that we do really well is that we look at,
we connect with our clients
and we meet them where they're at.
So it's not just about like,
we could go, you know, like we,
I've seen, what we've seen
from our clients in some cases
is they may say, hey, our mainframe
or our AS/400 is a, that's
an IT that's owned by IT.
And so we kind of own the
trajectory of that service.
Or maybe a product organization says,
hey, I wanna do something
totally different than what we're doing.
And they peel off
and go in a completely
different direction.
We have not really seen
that be successful.
What's necessary is that
we get everybody aligned
because we, at the end of the day,
like that legacy system is at the core,
and it's been there more than
likely for a few decades.
Business processes have
built up around that.
Business processes have built up
around those business processes.
And we can't simply just rip
that out without causing
massive business disruption.
And that's usually where we
see a lot of that failure.
So in our approach, we
want to pull together
all of our stakeholders,
build alignment across
our client organization,
and then based on that, we're
able to define a strategy
that works for everybody
that's focused on the key outcomes
that collectively we all want to meet.
So this is our La-Z-Boy,
our story that we're
extremely excited about this.
Like, so when we started with La-Z-Boy,
and we talked to them originally
in a half-day workshop,
they mentioned that they had a mainframe
and we said, oh, let's
talk more about that.
And they were resistant.
It was kind of like, hey,
we've tried to modernize this,
we've tried to work with
this a few different times.
We've gone through a few different passes.
We've got a team that's working on it
and they're kind of slowly
chipping away at it,
but we said, you know, let's
at least have the conversation
and let's talk about what's possible.
And as we went through, we kind
of realized that, you know,
there's some real opportunity
here for transformation
and like bringing our AWS expertise along
with the changes of Generative AI,
which they had not incorporated
into their process at time.
Opened up some doors and
opened up the ability for us
to do an AWS-funded assessment to look at
like what they currently had.
We mapped the dependency,
like first we got the code,
we used Amazon Q just to look
at it and fully understand it.
We were able to map the
dependencies to third party,
like any sort of external systems
that surrounded that core batch work,
the core batch workloads
that they were working on.
And so we were able to kind
of map out the full ecosystem.
And then from that we were able
to identify key stakeholders
for each one of those
parts of the organization,
engage them, get them involved.
So we got everyone together
and said, hey, is this
something that we want to do?
Like we can show you a path.
Like do we wanna make this real?
And, you know, we did it,
like we moved forward.
And so we moved forward
into a mobilized phase.
We used Q to accelerate our
infrastructure deployment.
We used Q as well to,
you know, to start
building out step functions
to replace the JCL for the jobs.
To, we used, we transformed
the COBOL into Python
and we deployed those as ECS tasks
and we modernized their DB2 environment
to a modern Aurora Postgres environment.
So we scaled out, like,
so during mobilize,
we used a subset of the workloads
just to prove out that process.
And then we went to full migrate,
we modernized the full set of workloads.
So at that point, we
were production-ready,
but we still, we had
built a testing process
to ensure that we had
functional equivalence
before we went into a full go live
state with decommissioning.
So at that point, we
basically set up this process
that could compare DB2
and Postgres and the data,
like as those jobs ran in synchronization,
and we saw some bugs that we fixed.
But I think one of the things
that is the most interesting
to me about this process
is that there were,
we found bugs that they never knew existed
that required us to rethink
some business processes.
And that was new for the
organization to, like,
that's the first time
that we're like, hey,
we're in this new world.
We're in this cloud world
where instead of stepping
away from the table
and saying, this is just
something we can't work with,
it's like, hey, not only
can we change this code,
we can change this process
here right now, you know.
But what else can we change?
What other processes can we modernize?
And to us, that's the
power of Zero Legacy.
I really appreciate you,
thank you so much for my talk.
I'm with Slalom.
Again, we're at Booth 625.
Love to have you join me over there
to continue the conversation.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)